some people ask the question of what
good is math what is the relationship
between math and physics
well sometimes math leads sometimes
physics leads sometimes they come
together because of course there's a use
for the mathematics for example in the
1600s Isaac Newton asked a simple
question if an apple Falls then does the
moon also fall that is perhaps one of
the greatest questions ever asked by a
member of Homo sapiens since the six
million years since we parted ways with
the Apes if an apple Falls does the moon
also fall Isaac Newton said yes the moon
Falls because of the inverse square law
so does an apple he had a unified theory
of the heavens but he didn't have the
mathematics to solve the falling moon
problem so what did he do he invented
calculus so calculus is a direct
consequence of solving the falling moon
problem in fact when you learn calculus
for the first time what is the first
thing you do it was the first thing you
do with calculus is you calculate the
motion of falling bodies which is
exactly how Newton calculated the
falling moon which opened up celestial
mechanics so here's a situation where
math and physics were almost co-joined
like like Siamese twins born together
for a very practical question how do you
calculate the motion of celestial bodies
then here comes I Stein asking a
different question and that is what is
the nature and origin of gravity
Einstein said that gravity is nothing
but the byproduct of curved space so why
am I sitting in this chair a normal
person would say I'm sitting in this
chair because gravity pulls me to the
ground but Einstein said no no no
there's no such thing as gravitational
pull the earth has curved this space
over my head and around my body so space
is pushing me into my chair
so to summarize Einstein's theory
gravity does not pull space pushes
but you see the pushing of the fabric of
space and time requires differential
calculus that is the language of curved
surfaces differential calculus which you
learn in fourth-year calculus so again
here's a situation where math and
physics were very closely combined but
this time math came first the theory of
curved surfaces came first
Einstein took that theory of curved
surfaces and then imported it into into
physics now we have string theory it
turns out that a hundred years ago math
and physics parted ways in fact when
Einstein proposed special relativity in
1905 that was also around the time of
the birth of topology the topology of
hyper dimensional objects spheres in 10
11 12 26 whatever dimension you want so
physics and mathematics parted ways math
went into hyperspace and mathematicians
said to themselves
aha finally we have found an area of
mathematics that has no physical
application whatsoever mathematicians
pride themselves as being useless they
love being useless
it's a is a Badge of Courage being
useless and they said the most useless
thing of all is a theory of differential
topology in higher dimensions well
physics plotted along for many decades
we worked out atomic bombs we worked out
stars we've worked out laser beams but
recently we discovered string theory and
string theory exists in 10 and 11
dimensional hyperspace not only that we
these dimensions are super they're super
symmetric a new kind of numbers that
mathematicians never talked about
evolved within string theory that's what
we call it super string theory well the
mathematicians were floored they were
shocked because all of a sudden out of
physics came new mathematics super
numbers super topology super
differential geometry all of a sudden we
had supersymmetric theories coming out
of physics
that then revolutionized mathematics and
so the goal of physics we believe is to
find an equation perhaps no more than
one inch long which will allow us to
unify all the forces of nature and allow
us to read the mind of God and what is
the key to that one inch equation
supersymmetry a symmetry that comes out
of physics not mathematics and has
shocked the world of mathematics but you
see all this is pure mathematics and so
the final resolution could be that God
is a mathematician and when you read the
mind of God we actually have a candidate
for the mind of God the mind of God we
believe is cosmic music the music of
strings resonating through eleven
dimensional hyperspace that is the mind
of God
you